Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Ashley Barrett.
Despite numerous headwinds, Vought
and our heroes have never been stronger.
We've seen double digit growth in pharma,
crime
fighting contracts and Vought
Plus subscribers.
The Vault Reconstruction project remains
ahead of schedule and under budget.
Black Noir has quietly been conducting
a critical mission overseas.
And finally, Homelander's approval
ratings are soaring.
Further proof America's sees right
through baseless accusations.
We've accomplished more in a few months
than my predecessor did in years.
But we've still got work to do.
Like selecting new members
of the seven to replace fallen
heroes like Mays and traders
like Starlight.
It's a new day for Vought.
Today's Heroes Tomorrow's Future.
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
The boys dropped the new Season
four teaser trailer, this time with Ashley
joking about everything that's happening
at the beginning of season four
or between season three and season four
and everything that Homelander is doing
with the Vought Company in the wake of
what happened in the Season three finale.
They make a couple big references
to what's going to be happening
at the beginning of season four too.
That will explain
some of your brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
I will be doing Season four episodes
just like I did four previous seasons.
I'll do a giveaway for Amazon
video memberships
when we get a little bit closer
to the season actually coming out.
But the way they're playing,
this is sort of like Kevin Feige
doing his Marvel Phase four announcement,
like she's doing an investor call
talking about all the exciting things,
quote unquote,
that are happening with the company,
despite all the chaos behind the scenes
that, you know, is actually going on,
because literally everything
that Vought says is just a PR piece
meant to pump up the company
and boost their share price.
It's all about making money.
Like literally everything they do,
every move they make, there's
no malice behind it, like no actual ego.
It's just Vought trying to make more money
being a more efficient company.
I love the way they're playing this, too.
It really is kind of like that.
Kevin Feige, Marvel
Phase four announcement.
I think the first one was in 2020
when he actually did the first big one,
just talking about all the Disney
Plus series they had because she does
reference the Vought plus that they have,
which is a big Disney plus parody.
This is like their big streaming network
that's meant to be a parody of HBO, Max
and all the real life streaming networks
with Vought.
Plus, you have the power to control
the greatest content in the world.
Enjoy the action and the excitement
of all of your favorite Vought Studio
films and series plus. Stay informed
with reliable news you can count on
from people you can trust.
Plus, never miss a Game 24 seven coverage
of your favorite sports teams.
Plus, plus,
timeless stories of heroes who may be gone
but never forgotten.
Plus, plus, plus, plus VI.
Plus the world's premiere super streaming
service.
Sign up now.
They even had another joke recently
about Vought plus, quote unquote,
raising their prices, but giving people
less content like less stuff
in somehow that was a good thing.
Like we're screwing you over,
but it's a good thing
in the way
that during all the boys seasons,
you see all the people for Vought, like
Stan, Edgar, Ashley, everyone just kind of
spinning things to make it look like
things are going really well
for Vought and that you just waffle on
and tell people a bunch of lies.
Zoom in, enhance.
You also price out the Kyron for votes
award here
most valuable company is for 2023
and they control the awards.
So the whole joke here is that
it's only been a couple of weeks,
like within a couple of weeks,
the beginning of the year.
They're saying they're already the world's
best company.
We'll see how things go for them
in a couple more months
when things slowly
start to go off the rails even more.
This is sort of the fulfillment
of Stan Edgar's prophecy
that he gave to Homelander
when he was kicked out the door.
Essentially,
when they basically fired him,
like after Victoria
Neuman threw him under the bus.
He basically told Homelander that it was
the beginning of the end for him.
Like even though it seemed like
the company was riding
high, like there was a temporary boost
to their share price.
So it seemed like the company was more
profitable by throwing him under the bus.
And it seemed like Homelander
had gained a bunch more popularity
with certain segments of the population,
like there was a caveat to that.
But Stan Edgar was trying to tell him
that he was misreading the signs.
Like, No, no, no,
this is the beginning of the end,
because eventually
you're going to do something
to screw things up because you don't know
how to run a company.
You're both a terrible person,
like you're an awful person,
but you're also really bad at business.
And eventually he would screw up so badly
that it would hurt the company
and nobody would be there to clean it up
or to clean up his image
or hide what he had done.
And then people
will start to turn against him.
So the whole idea is that Homelander
is starting to drink his own Kool-Aid.
This started to happen
at the end of season
three with that funny laugh
that everybody's been posting as a meme
for just a hot second.
When he killed that dude, he realized
he messed up like, Oh, no, I've done it.
I've done the thing that Stan
Edgar told me that I was going to do,
and everything is over now.
But when his hardcore fans
start to cheer him on and love him
no matter what, like for a second,
they're not sure what to do.
But then Todd is like, Okay, fine.
Like his brain does this amazing backflip
to try and justify what just happened
within a split second.
And then they start cheering him
on. Homeowners like, Oh,
maybe I can do anything,
maybe I can get away with everything.
And that's meant to be him
misreading the science.
Like the whole idea is
it is just that small, hardcore fan base
that will act like that.
There's actually a much larger
part of the population
where his popularity declined.
Ashley told him about that
earlier in the season
when he had a couple of funny moments
where he was talking about
his relative popularity points when he had
his big rant on public television.
It polarized his position,
so a bunch of people started hating him
even more in a bunch of people
sort of loving him even more.
Eventually, he's
just going to keep messing up doing crazy
WTF things,
so that'll polarize things even more.
And more and more people
will slowly turn against him.
But the whole idea is that
Homelander is just seeing the stuff
that's like right in front of his face.
He can only see the people
that are cheering for him.
He's not looking at all
the other people that hate him.
The growth in pharma that Ashley
is talking about, the white line,
that shooting up sharply was Stan Edgar's
long term plan for compound B
in making the company is profitable,
as it could potentially be.
The whole idea with Vought,
like I said, is
that the company is meant to be egoless,
like the whole grand plan is it?
The company just wants to earn more money
no matter what the cost.
But there's no ego,
no morality in the equation.
Stan Edgar
didn't want to subjugate the world.
He didn't want power for power sake.
He just wanted to make the company
more profitable.
But that's it, which is evil
in and of itself,
as opposed to Homelander,
who's all about ego.
He's being evil
in a more traditional kind of way.
They actually had a conversation
about that.
I think it was at the beginning of season
two where Stan Edgar had
this come to Jesus moment with Homelander,
where he's like, Look,
here's the reality of the situation.
You think that Vought is popular
because of you
and what the seven are doing.
But here's really
what the company is about.
Here's what we really care about.
He told him the true
back story of the company,
how they were started by a Nazi
German scientist who defected after World
War Two with his wife,
who was Stormfront like it was meant
to be part of Stormfront origin Story two
and as part of Operation Paperclip,
he continued trying to develop Compound
B in the United States,
creating Vought America
like the American arm of the company
Soldier Boy, who was one of the Americans
first attempts at creating a superhero.
Even though Stormfront was the actual
first one soldier boy was like
the next person that they tried it on.
They continued trying
to refine the formula in.
The whole idea is
that they had always viewed themselves
as a pharmaceutical company.
All the stuff with superheroes
was just sort of a side effect.
Like, what happened is, is they would test
compound V iterations,
like they would try to make the formula
better and better.
And each time
they'd have these superheroes
that were left over
that they couldn't kill,
like they couldn't
just get rid of them easily.
They viewed people like Soldier
Boy is sort of like merchandise products
that they created,
and they had him just sitting around.
So they had to find a way
to make the company more money.
They had all this extra quote
unquote product
and all these extra supers
that they were creating.
Thus rose
the Disney side of their business
where they started merchandizing things.
They tried to use those superheroes
to create more profit, more products,
more merchandise for people to buy
movies, television shows, if you like.
If Disney found a way to create Compound
V, they created all these superheroes.
And then in order
to make more money off of it,
they created the Marvel Universe
and all the stuff that you see
in real life with Marvel.
If all the Marvel superheroes
did actually have powers, that's why
the boys is meant to be satire.
Like they parody a lot of these real world
organizations and real world events.
So in the flashbacks with Soulja Boy,
Soulja Boy was like an early attempt
at that.
Stan Edgar felt like
he could do a better job with like, okay,
we've gone as far as we can
go making money with this character here.
We need to try something even better.
I have a good idea In
that idea was Homelander.
That was part of the joke of Soulja Boy
being Homelander's father.
They use the genetic material
from Soulja Boy to create Homelander
but Pump's way, way more Compound V
in a more
refined version of the formula
into Baby Homelander.
And a lot of people are wondering
if Stormfront
was the genetic material for his mother.
It's always possible too, and that would
definitely be in the tone of the boys.
Homelander secretly getting it on
with a version of his mother.
He already has that crazy mommy complex.
It would just be such a weird
twist on the character.
Aya Cash even joked about that
when they were doing promos for the boys.
Season two in season three,
but one of the titles of one of the season
three episodes was the five year plan.
In the whole idea is that was Stan Edgar's
final plant, like his grand ultimate
plan to completely pivot the company away
from their superhero business.
Like if Disney totally stopped
doing all the regular Disney stuff
and just started being more like visor,
like he wanted to turn them into a pure
pharmaceutical company
in the traditional sense
because it was way more efficient.
They could make way more money
by just selling the temporary compound
that they had just
developed to the military.
It is starting to become too much trouble
to run their superhero business
like it was too much of a hassle for them.
And it wasn't as profitable
as it could have been.
But remember,
the important thing is that Stan Edgar
wasn't trying to do all this, like
take over the government,
basically take over the White House,
the presidency with Victoria Neuman
in that long term play
because he wanted power for power sake,
like he wanted to control the White House.
Yes, the government.
Yes, But that's just to clear the path
for Vought
to do whatever they wanted to do
without any kind of regulations,
like no more FDA,
no more health organizations
regulating them, telling them
what they could do, what they could test.
Compound the on his real ultimate plan
was just to make Vought
a more profitable company like that.
Is it?
That's all he did confess
to hating Homelander.
They're like, Oh,
I absolutely hate that dude.
That's why it was so ironic
that he was planning
on getting rid of Homelander
and the other superheroes.
Like, Oh, in a couple of years
you're all going to be defunct.
Like, we won't care about
you will be way more profitable
because we'll just be selling
this temporary compound B to the military.
We don't need you anymore.
The problem is that Homelander has God
tier power.
He's meant to be the most powerful person
on the planet.
Nigh unkillable.
And when you tell a person like that
who's mentally unstable
that they're going to be irrelevant
and you don't care about them,
they don't take it too well
and they're just part of the slow descent.
As he gets crazier
and crazier in future seasons.
Like how many more seasons
the show winds up running,
they'll probably at least
go to season five.
I don't know if they'll go beyond that,
but I think the showrunner said
that they could potentially go beyond that
if they want to actually joke
about the crime.
Fighting two
is about the whole A-Train Black
Hawk storyline in the Collateral Damage.
They even talked about that
during season one.
The whole idea that superheroes
cause more damage than they prevent
because pretty much all of them
are terrible at using their powers.
I'd be like
if you found someone on the street,
literally, it just gave them superpowers.
Like the next day
they started trying to fight crime.
Oh, it would be a disaster.
The Vought Reconstruction Project is them
fixing Vought Tower in the wake of that
final battle with Soulja Boy in season
three, they blew up part of the tower.
They have the jokes about Black Tower
being on a quote unquote secret mission.
And that's why nobody's seen him.
Yes, that's the real reason
the showrunner did say that the actor
who plays
black noir would be back on the show,
but he didn't say whether or not
he be a completely new character
because he's been wearing the mask
so he could just play another character.
But also in the comics,
they can use Compound V
to bring people back from the dead,
bring superheroes back from the dead.
So it's possible
for them to this literally
bring black noir back from the dead.
Usually when they bring them back, though,
it doesn't work perfectly
like they bring them back.
Wrong Pet cemetery style
actually upholds the lie about Queen
Mae being dead,
even though she knows she survived.
This is the one good thing that she's done
that we've seen.
It just seems like
she's completely capitulated.
So I don't know
if she's going to redeem herself at all
before the end of the series.
They're throwing starlight under the bus
for leaving the seven formerly,
like she formally left.
She's no longer
going to be part of the seven
during season four and joined the boys.
The new members on the seven
she's talking about
are probably just a combination of A-Train
rejoining the seven
formerly in another new character
they'll introduced in season four.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is playing a character
during the boys Season
four, just continuing their tradition
of doing supernatural cameos.
We'll see
if they eventually get Jared Padalecki
to play a character
that would complete everything.
If you spot spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
and they'll probably keep releasing
teaser trailers and clips like this
between season three and season four.
So I'll just do more videos.
As we get more footage,
there'll be a bunch of Super Bowl trailers
in a couple weeks.
Of course I'll do videos for all that,
make sure to enable loops for my channel
so you don't miss that.
My full Last of US Episode three video
will post on Sunday after they release it.
Everyone click here for All my Last of US
episodes and click here for my Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.